c'est bon pour les trois cartes
écartées on distribue C cartes à chaque
joueur face cachée je classique plus
moderne et familiaux l'association entre
quatre jeux a lancé son premier festival
dédié au jeux de société à SaintQuentin
en Yveline l'objectif rassembler des
joueurs de tous les âges autour d'une
même passion on est heureux de passer ce
moment ensemble et c'est que du bonheur
c'est bien organisé quand on voit le la
variété de jeux qu'il y a ça il y a
forcément un jeu pour chaque enfant et
c'est un plaisir un large choix de jeu
réparti sur une vingtaine de tables
quels que soi les goûts et compétences
les joueurs occasionnel ou confirmé
pouvaent trouver leur bonheur mais ça ça
compte un jeton il faut en rendre c'est
l'occasion de découvrir des nouveaux
jeux on en a pas mal à la maison plein
les placards mais il y en a encore à
découvrir ça peut donner des idées de
cadeaux Noël approche à grandb
finalement et là c'est bien possible que
ça finisse sur la liste du Père Noël le
marbleel cette année voà l'occasion
également de rencontrer auteur et
auditeur de jeux de société pour
échanger avec eux découvrir les
coulisses de la création de ces jeux
parfois né au cœur des ivelines on a
beau en tant que créateur avoir toutes
les idées qu'on veut à la
fin la réalité c'est le contact avec le
public on est une association locale
encrée dans une dans un environnement
local aussi et donc c'est créateurs de
jeux local on les on les côtoie il
viennent à l'association on les voit un
petit peu tout le temps donc c'était
important de les mettre en avant aussi
aujourd'hui avec 3 personnes présentes
la première édition de ce festival a été
un succès l'association prévoit déjà une
seconde édition l'année
prochaine